voters across four states were pushing
for a green wave on Election Day Green
why marijuana legislation is what we're
talking about passed in three of them
but not North Dakota Michigan became the
tenth state to approve recreational
marijuana and Missouri and Utah voted to
legalize medical marijuana Colorado
spearheaded the legal sale of
recreational marijuana back in 2014 last
year Denver brought in nearly forty five
million dollars in taxes from pot sales
more than 3.6 million of that will go to
a new marijuana awareness program for
teenagers Barry Petersen shows us how
this new campaign differs from that just
say no message of the 1980s there has
been an increase in juvenile marijuana
violations in Denver since 2015
it's like jeopardy for juveniles and the
topic is pop this slickly produced game
show is shown where teens get their
information on social media false and
the same quiz show format plays out in
classes across the city what percentage
of Dever youth see regular marijuana use
as a risky behavior is it a 35 percent B
15 % c 87 percent or d 56 percent like
vents Trujillo's North High School
classroom the only two teens to get it
right word these two teams so 35% of
Denver teens see it as a risky behavior
and learning more is making kids use
marijuana less says Ashley Kilroy who
runs the pot education program for the
city so what a numbers showing in terms
of teen use with teenagers and the
numbers are showing that youth has
dropped significantly the city's point
of pride is a survey showing the number
of kids who have reported using pot in
the last 30 days dropped from 26% to
less than 21 percent over the last two
years that means that 79 percent of your
friends aren't using marijuana that
using marijuana is not the social norm
but from the stew
we got a big dose of teenage doubt about
the program that the adults aren't
trusting kids with all the facts says
junior Isiah Diaz there's obviously
medical benefits to it otherwise it
wouldn't be legal so it doesn't seem
fair that once it's not properly
balanced Kenna
al ghul is a senior I think they are
afraid to tell us the good side just
because they think they might influence
the way we think like they might yeah
they might encourage us to use it it's a
tough call for teachers like Trujillo if
you were allowed to give more
information not just about the bad but
that make you more credible do you think
in the eyes of these teenagers yeah
because I think at the end of the day
they want the whole truth so if you were
able to bring both sides I think more
students would be in tune with that
which is down in truth the program is a
lot like marijuana laws in America a
work in progress but so far it's hitting
the key goal it's set persuading more
and more kids to give pot a pass
marijuana can damage which two major
organs in the human body a brain and
lungs a brain and lungs check the Bob
for CBS this morning Barry Petersen
Denver I'm all for the more education
about that there's people to think it
it's not dangerous and doesn't have side
effects they're wrong and if it's been
legalized that that's the implicit
message now it's interactive - I like
that and I like that it's very creative
and very clever and gets the kids
engaged and they're paying attention
they're getting right answers that's
good perhaps coming to a Michigan
television station